the Joe Rogan experience what's
fascinating to me is everyone talked
about Conor McGregor right especially
when you talk about 155 and with Conor
and max Holloway Connors never looked
back when a fight that guy back - even
though I'm better the thing that gets
Connor out of bed I think is the
challenge and making history
I think if khabib or max were to win
that would be a new challenge
and he'd be an underdog against khabib
and with max Holloway the FC have a
history at 55 especially if it could be
were to win I think we see Connor take
that fight now because he goes that's
not found great well I'm the best that
moving backwards hitting dudes I bet you
I can beat that guy and we see him I
think we see him take that fight mmm and
I've never said that before I've always
I know Dana said oh they're gonna fight
in Russia I'm like honor fighting him
and then I think I'm like when we think
of all the challenges in comics career
and what gets him going it's not people
behind him it's always when people that
guy's the best he was cool give me that
guy may be similar max Holloway hmm yeah
if max wins for sure they have a rematch
100%
the thing about khabib is you go he's
got a wonder who's avoiding him there's
a difference there everybody yeah see
the difference is max is one of the best
fighters on the planet no doubt he's one
of my top one of my top guys maybe he's
ever top featherweight of all time but
people aren't avoiding him no it's like
I said kabhi was a different animal they
are fine guys I referenced this I said I
said if you gave me a choice to make the
walk against Francis or khabib I'm
picking Francis because there's a quick
death ahead in the third row but it's
quick khabib it's like an Isis video
it's gonna be longer all now it's me a
[ __ ] nightmare that you're not gonna
forget yeah he's gonna beat your body
into a pulp but it the worst is he
breaks you where it's like oh you were
good at this and people thought you were
mentally strong watch this now your
entire family and friends gonna see how
much of a [ __ ] you are as I bash your
brains in round after round after round
after
you see him break guys too though you
see like this something happens to them
well they just they give in to the
inevitability of getting rag doll he's
just better yeah oh the only person
that's gonna beat him it's not a person
it's a [ __ ] grizzly bear you know
it's like [ __ ] this man
and you see it see into their eyes we're
just changes we're just like no not
happening
how many rounds four four more rounds of
this this is terrible if he wins and he
beats Holloway I guarantee he was
calling out McGregor
Tyron he wants the GSP fight khabib
wants GSP holy [ __ ] that's what I hear
whoa that's the set 170 hmm whoa what a
great fight right it's a perfect time to
do it right now right GSP wins by rear
naked choke against Bisping at 185 says
he doesn't want to fight at 85 again
here take your belt
suck it yes yes PA just go suck it good
take you I know I told you I'd fight
their sock
[Applause]